a bit late in 15 seconds
gone yes that's what you get if you go to the
performance
not that it would be so great now
probably but of course not the
slightest idea to go again
well
well somehow i have a bit of a clue
as to actually going or something like that  just
something where i feel at home now
let's do normal moves jona
1 right away from the i5 maybe
yes and me there more f3 nothing good anymore just a
moment is that because the kjc
beat six or
that actually looks pretty
clear from the economy
two  pawns more for nothing
yes you
don't really want the structured ones but I could take you
five no idea d5 also
comes the 21 student has me very simple
the two pawns even if it's not
so nice here only
five bishops should be enough simple  the five then to me
check
please now science foundation I want
more is lost anyway but cicek
comfortable with b5 he put away
before h  nothing going on I think